all right i'm going to let our listeners
in behind the scenes here for just a
moment we've just experienced real
technical difficulties
we were supposed to be joined by matt
gourley who has a babysitter emergency
yeah this is the babysitter that looks
after him apparently not his child uh
and matt
couldn't be on the zoom he was going to
be on a zoom but there's a technical
difficulty yeah during this technical
difficulty while we're waiting for matt
who still can't seem to get
onto the zoom for some reason yeah we're
sitting here and we're waiting and you
take a phone call from your mom yes
and suddenly i'm no longer in the united
states okay no i'm now listen i'm you
know how tolerant i am of other cultures
and how much i love the armenians do you
why oh listen
but listen
you
started talking in armenian yes could
you give us just a sample of the kinds
of things you were saying cause i was
sitting here
i'm very proud of my people
died to come to this country you know
okay it was an arduous journey and they
fought hard to carve out a
spot here in the united states right
okay and so i i thought i was here in
the u.s when suddenly i was transported
to armenia well the united states is in
big melting pot there are a lot of
immigrants here who speak different
languages and i love that about this
country yes i really do you do sometimes
say what is that mishmish or no no
that's insensitive i would never say
that yeah but tell me what you were
saying because it's it's fascinating to
me i'm sitting here and i know you as
sona and suddenly yeah uh well tell us
what you were saying so my mom called
and we are you know we
feeding the boys now is is like a
process because they're eating more
solids and you know not as much milk
and so my mom doesn't
fully know yet how to how to do that and
handle it so she called me and she was
just like inch
you know uh each time your mom like
and you know
what are you saying here what what is
what is it she's like i don't know what
to do right now i'm like did he sleep
and you know
you know did he drink milk like but i
think that when
when my mom calls and i start speaking
her in armenian you always do this bit
where you're like what was that what was
that well it's very
it's very arresting it's very shocking
i'm just not used to it yeah now we're
here in our new podcast studios i own
this building and i own this podcast
studio okay and i think of this tell me
if i'm wrong as sovereign
u.s soil you know okay and um okay am i
allowed to forbid you no i'm speaking a
foreign language in in this building no
you're absolutely that's a hundred
percent not okay
to say that someone can't speak a
foreign language well i feel like this
is like you know the way in an embassy
is sacred soil you can speak different
languages and embassies there's nowhere
where this is okay that you're talking i
feel like this is all i've ever wanted
is my own clubhouse and now i finally
you know we've always you know i was
working at 30 rock for years and then
i'm working at warner brothers i'm
always there at someone else's behest
now finally willy wonka i'm being willy
wonka i have my own chocolate factory
this is i'm pee-wee and this is my
playhouse so i do feel like i'm allowed
to act like an insane emperor and say
things like what what are you speaking
no more of that are you only english are
you upset that you can't understand it
and that you wish you could speak
another language and be cool like me
like does
i feel like you're just a little jealous
i don't think i'm jealous you're jealous
i don't think so i think you're jealous
you're jealous because i can speak
another language and i like switch on
and off it's really shocking i remember
the first time almost 11 12 years ago
when i heard you talking to your mom
outside my door i had no idea that
you spoke this this foreign tongue
um but listen let's do a thing where i
speak to you in english and you answer
me in armenian okay i want people to
understand okay how are you today
[Music]
i love this champion i wish to
um sort of sabotage the united states of
america
um will you help me in my evil scheme
yeah mortgage
yes
yes bad usa yeah yes we must bring down
the bad united states we must work
within the united states to bring it
down as secret spies don't you agree
sona
don't you agree
stop laughing spy we're here to destroy
america from within
no no
yes
yes
i agree yeah what's attack when they're
least expected yeah yes in the night in
the night what is the the plan here i
don't know it just sounds like i love
that i love that you're probably saying
things like um they like boiled pork and
also i'm saying really mean things about
you specifically are you really yeah
yeah what are you saying i'm saying uh i
hate working here
your skin is super white i've never seen
someone's skin so white before oh okay
and uh all right then you just kept
talking about taking on america
[Laughter]
we're gonna attack in the night when
they expect at least we're gonna attack
who who are we attacking i'm not sure i
didn't have my plan all worked out but
you answered speaking in english so
people what is the language that
armenian is closest to is it close to
russian no it's not what is it what is
it what is it close to well you know tax
speaks russian because he grew up in the
soviet union right um and you know
there's armenians from lebanon who speak
arabic and there's
armenians from iran who speak arabic and
my parents are from istanbul so they
speak turkish too this is cool i love
how multicultural you are and i love
that you're bringing this perspective to
the podcast and all i have to say to you
is in my building english only
only english
why are you saying it with an accent i
don't know i say english only
i still believe that if you speak
english with an accent other people can
understand you who don't speak english i
say english only
that doesn't make any sense my building
english only
i have no idea what i'm this is insane
because i know that it upsets you to
speak a different language i'm only ever
going to speak in armenian from now on
okay so what's uh wrap up this segment
um you and your tongue and and me and
mine okay okay oh gosh
thank you sona
thanks for stopping by the podcast
it was nice having you here today and
how are you so now there anything to say
to the fans before we slip over the
rainbow and say good night yeah duner
talk with them ah see people from
different cultures can
oh no i like america no i won't attack
it
what is this [ __ ] i don't know i don't
understand what the bible is like trying
to make it sound like you're up to
something bad why because it just is
amusing you're saying the english part
and you're saying the whole plan in
english and so i don't understand what
the thing is i wha what's what's the bit
that you're like planning a thing but
your part is in english and you're
saying what the plan is in english
what's happening i love what's the bit
what's the bit here
what's the bit why don't you trust me
i'm the bit captain i've been in the bit
business for a long time just trust me
this bit doesn't make sense don't say
bit captain in the bit business all
right stupid right
this was a waste good night all of you
it was a wasted segment
say good night sonia your own special
tongue
you